Today lots of girls play sports.
But, for a long time,
girls were not encouraged
to kick,
throw,
run,
jump,
shoot,
slide,
or hit like boys.
So, why did things change?
And how much have they changed?
Are girls and boys treated equally
when it comes to sports?
To begin to answer these questions,
we have to look back.
In 1972, Congress passed
a law called Title IX,
which protected girls and women
from discrimination in schools,
colleges,
and universities.
This included discrimination
in school-sponsored sports.
At that time, only 15%
of college athletes were women,
and in high schools,
only 7% of athletes were girls.
Female athletes didn't get
a lot of support either
and often had to provide
their own uniforms and equipment.
It was Title IX that forced
school administrators
to make sports more equal.
But what does equal mean in sports?
The government developed rules
to measure equality
under two general categories:
participation
and treatment.
In the early days of Title IX,
the number of girls
playing sports was so low
that it would have been very difficult
for schools to suddenly provide
exactly the same number
of opportunities for girls and boys.
Instead, the government wrote rules
that gave schools three options, or tests,
to demonstrate fairness
in opportunities for girls.
The three tests are
proportionality,
progress,
and satisfied interests.
A school can pick which test to follow.
Proportionality means
that girls should receive
the same percentage
of athletic opportunities
as the percentage of girls
in the student body.
So, if 51% of students are girls,
then girls should have approximately
51% of the opportunities to play sports.
The second test, progress,
requires schools to make up for the days
when girls had fewer opportunities
by adding new sports for girls
on a regular basis.
The third test asks if girls interested
in athletics are satisfied.
Under this test, a school
must regularly ask
female students what sports
they are interested in
and also take into consideration
the popularity
of certain sports in the area
where the school is located.
It must, then, add teams according
to the girls' interests.
Another important part of Title IX
is that it doesn't just look at how many
athletic opportunities
are available to each sex
but whether those opportunities
are of equal quality.
Specifically, Title IX requires equality
between boys and girls teams for things
like equipment and supplies,
publicity,
the scheduling of games
and practice times,
and the quality and number of coaches.
Girls should also have equal access
to locker rooms,
practice spaces,
and competitive facilities,
as well as medical services.
So, if the best time to play
basketball is on Friday nights
because that's when
most parents and fans can come,
then the girls and boys teams
should take turns playing on Friday night.
If boys teams play
in a stadium with lights,
scoreboards,
and concession stands,
then girls teams must have
the same opportunity,
either by sharing those facilities
or getting their own of equal quality.
But, as we all know,
just because a law exists
doesn't mean that everybody follows it.
School officials are responsible
for making sure there
is fairness in sports,
but you can help, too,
by keeping an eye on your own school.
Look around.
Are there a lot more boys
than girls who play sports?
Is the boys' soccer field
better than the girls'?
Are athletic trainers available
to all teams equally?
Does the baseball team get
new uniforms every year,
while the softball team gets
them every three years?
If you think there might be
inequality in your schools,
you can approach a school administrator,
a parent,
or the Office of Civil Rights,
a government agency
that makes sure schools
comply with Title IX
because equality
is important for everyone,
both on the field and off.